we're here at the state capital in
Austin during a national school choice
speak at the Texas school choice rally
to talk to parents and education
reformers about the promises and
pitfalls of education savings accounts
the next frontier in the school choice
movement without school choice
there will be no reform of public
education in America it's the children's
future I say oh joy Texas has a
reputation as a business friendly state
that favors the free market and consumer
choice over heavy government regulation
but when it comes to education reform
and school choice they're actually
behind the curve
Texas is behind the rest of the country
when it comes to school choice thirty
states have passed over 60 different
school choice programs and really I'm
ashamed that Texas has passed non like
those in many states parents and Texas
must send their children to the public
schools in their district unless they
have the cash for a private school many
choice is only available to the
wealthiest we have school choice already
we do have one victory but you have to
be rich to have no choice fight many of
the people who fight school choice are
sending their kids to private school
without school choice Texas ranks among
the lowest and combined SAT scores it is
in the bottom quarter nationally in
reading proficiency one out of every
four students fail to graduate high
school and black and Hispanic students
are twice as likely to leave school
before getting a diploma than white
students political leaders have
supported school choice initiatives to
raise education standards but lawmakers
often reject those bills but this year
is different the new governor has made
school choice a priority as has the
incoming Trump administration I think
the momentum for Texas school choice is
really growing you know when we look at
our economy and we look at the way that
Texas touts freedom free markets big
business all of those things we really
think that now is the time for parents
to have educational freedom in Texas and
Texas isn't settling for charter schools
but pushing for something even more
radical education savings accounts known
as essays which would give parents the
ability to spend
money on education options outside the
traditional school system the key to the
education savings account is it's much
like a medical savings account people
the parents would get a card and they
can spend their child's education
dollars on qualified education expenses
the Texas ESA program would follow the
model of Nevada which introduced the
savings accounts last year if it goes
into effect parents would receive a
debit card for five thousand dollars
that could be used for tutors test prep
private school or other educational cost
the fact that you have that flexibility
to pay for school tuition to pay for
home school materials as well as pay for
therapy it covers a lot of angles and a
lot of different needs for different
kids advocates are hopeful that an
incoming Trump administration will
provide momentum for esa s Trump has
proposed repurposing twenty billion in
federal education dollars and giving
them to the states to be used for school
choice and other voucher programs I'm
very excited about the administration
from president Trump all the way down to
our governor here in Texas we see a
momentum and support for school choice
we believe that with President Trump
we're going to return power to the
states and make sure that we remove any
government burdens and controls over our
local schools so that they too can
flourish I don't want it to be a federal
program because I believe education is a
state issue and the states should take
that action but I so welcome his
recognition that parents should be in
control of their child's education
spending and while there's been the
predictable backlash from public school
supporters over diverting money from
public education some traditional choice
supporters are also wary of the ESA
program we need to reinvest that money
back in the public school system and
leave those who have private schools
such as
schools are legally private schools in
the state of Texas leave them alone
keep the regulations out in a way those
in the faith-based community worry that
taking government money will mean more
regulation and some fiscal conservatives
are concerned about the lack of
accountability over what parents can
spend ESA dollars on those that are
concerned that parents may not spend
this money wisely I again say I trust
parents more than I trust education
bureaucrats and even religious schools
should compete to see what students want
to go there no one should be forced to
go to a school that teaches a religion
contrary to their own beliefs
we are against an establishment of
religion but were for the free exercise
of religious liberty making education
and making educators of your own
individual child accountable to the
parent where the parent is saying this
is what is good for my child that is a
good thing I do believe that this could
become a model for all the nation I
think the momentum is here in Texas for
school choice I recognize the other team
the other side is really working to
protect the status quo but that is
simply not acceptable it is failing too
many kids and we need change and we need
it now we can't wait two more years
[Music]